[Music]
you did such a phenomenal job in this
season if they're tuned reasons why how
do you feel about how the show ended I
mean there's a crazy cliffhanger how do
you feel about the ending you know I
think in season two we came back to a
season two quite closely up the back of
season one and in season one you know
the approach that we had we didn't know
you know how it was gonna resonate we
just wanted to go out and tell a story
in the most authentic way possible and I
think that that was really one thing
that we've maintained in season two was
just trying to tell stories and and
trying to cover issues that are so
prevalent important in an authentic and
unflinching way season three is of
course greenlit but you posted this
Instagram seemingly bidding farewell to
Hannah is there a place for Hannah
in season three Hannah Hannah is wrapped
Hannah is officially done on 13 reasons
why and you know I feel really proud to
have been a part of the project and I
think that 13 reasons why you know even
though if I'm not every time it isn't in
the season 3 her story is something I'm
gonna carry with me and I think also a
lot of other people are gonna carry with
them and I just hope that if anything I
can be there in a small way on social
media but yeah yeah I want you to
forgive me would you come back for
flashbacks at all um if I mean if they
want me that's all up to them but Hannah
Hannah is Hannah's done Hannah's raps
I'm so glad I got to tell her story it
was really special
[Music]
[Applause]